mais c'est vrai que c'est l'une des
choses que ce jean pierre mas montre en
exemple moi je n'aime pas tellement
parler de modèle j'ai pas de modèle en
revanche jean pierre était un exemple
dans beaucoup de domaines et cette
liberté que qu'il avait dans l'exercice
de cette fonction de présentateurs c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils voulaient pas
de prompteur disette avec ses fiches on
le voyait parfois lire mais ils avaient
cette liberté aussi distillé permettait
voilà de très à l'aise dans cet exercice
là et c'est vrai que c'est quelque chose
que j'essaie d'appliquer aussi cette
fameuse liberté parce qu'on se dit c'est
quand même le seul fou et moi j'aime le
foot comme tôt avoir quitté de toi même
le fauteuil du jt de 20 heures c'est
incroyable c'est sain que voilà on vit
en plus tu faisais des audiences
incroyable c'est avec moi qui étais
venue était devenu un voilà c'était une
habitude moi je vois je regardais
content je regrette le temps de cogiter
et c'est vrai que ça aussi c'est la
liberté non c'est pas ça aussi tu avais
envie de oui oui c'est à dire que
dans moi le parcours que j'ai eu à la
télévision ce qui m'a le plus marqué ce
qui ne correspondent plus ce sont les
immersions que j'ai fait avec grand
bonheur pendant cinq ans et qui était
aussi un exercice de proximité tout
comme jean-pierre a changé sur le fond
la pratique d'un journalisme qu'on
disait nationale mais qui était en
vérité à ces parisiens il a rendu le
journal télévisé vraiment nationale il
s'intéresse à la france dans sa
diversité et dans dans tous ces pays
entre guillemets plurielle et bien c'est
vrai que l'immersion c'était aussi un
exercice à proximité donc la proximité
c'est aussi un autre point commun qu'on
a après avoir lâché c'est quoi votre
site et que votre première rencontre
avec jean-pierre première fois que vous
avez alors la première fois que je les
ai vus jeu
j'étais j'arrivais à tf1 avant de
prendre l'antenne le 13 juillet 2006
j'ai fait un mois de préparation donc
je faisais des numéros zéro etc et je
les croisais en mai dans les cours et
c'est vrai que c'est quelqu'un qui était
un qui est impressionnant il y avait il
y avait avalé trois monstres sacrés à la
rédaction de tf1 c'était patrick poivre
d'arvor jean pierre pernaut et puis
claire chazal qui divisait les week-ends
et c'est vrai que c'est moi en tant que
très jeune journaliste à l'époque gp
j'ai été impressionné par par ces
personnages là alors est ce maintenant
c'est tous réveillés c'est vrai qu'elle
demande avait on a eu du mal à y croire
même mais aujourd'hui on a du mal à
croire que jean pierre reçoit parti
isabelle voulait dire quelque chose oui
je voulais dire parce que justement
quand harry roselmack a été intéressée à
intéresser tf1 ils voulaient le tester
sur la météo des pins et moi je me
souviens de jean-pierre me disant c'est
ridicule le potentiel de ce mec il faut
pas le mettre à la météo faut le mettre
au journal déjà il ya michel est
excellent sur i télé harris franchement
si le au canal avait laissé partir pour
qu'ils veulent faire la météo sur tf1
j'étais pas encore dans le groupe canal
mais on chez possible alors s'avérer été
l'épisode météo était bien avant 2006 et
c'est en 2000 à date n'avait pas
approché pour la météo on n'avait pas
trouvé d'accord à cette époque puisque
là encore les libertés je ne voulais pas
m'enfermer dans cet exercice là j'aurais
fais avec plaisir si on m'avait donné la
possibilité de faire aussi travailler
elle sait y faire ce métier de
journaliste à l'époque ça n'a pas été
possible et donc j'avais refusé cette
offre et quelques années plus tard je
suis revenu pour le 20 heures alors
isabelle aujourd'hui on a vu des images
aussi partout
concernant jean pierre c'est vrai que
c'est un matin on sait utiliser on sait
tous ce réveillon on n'y croyait pas on
pensait qu'on avait fait un mauvais rêve
en est absolument et puis en plus comme
on est obligé vous comme moi de tartiner
dessus si j'ose dire d'en parler d'en
parler on n'a même pas le temps moi ça
m'a frappé ce matin juste avant la
tranche principal je me souviens c'est
vrai qu'on n'a même pas le temps de deux
de faire son deuil quelque part amical
moi ça m'a vraiment ça m'a vraiment
frappé et en revanche quand j'ai
revisionné des dizaines de deux
séquences y compris hier soir chez vous
ce qui m'a frappé c'est le ce que
j'appelle le sourire qui dure dans
l'immédiat vous avez des gens qui
sourient aide et vous avez le dos tourné
le sourire n'est plus là et lui il était
vraiment attachants et foucault chez
nous raconter ce matin que vraiment il
était quand il l'avait vu bas en
décembre il l'avait trouvé fatigué mais
que tout de suite père noël n'était
crois que je suis fini et ben est tout
de suite et lille ce sourire est revenu
moi ça m'a rassuré semi ce temps que le
sourire est là jean-pierre sera là mais
pour moi c'est le plus beau sourire de
la télévision française je suis d'accord
et ce qui est assez surprenant c'est que
pour quelqu'un qui présentait des news
actuellement c'était plutôt on reste un
sérieux enfin est une forme séduit c'est
quelqu'un qui est si vrai qu'il savait
sourire à l'antenne en présentant des
anciens et quand il va d'ailleurs hier
dans le magnet donne dans un des
magnétos on interroge les gens dans la
rue en leur demandant jean-pierre permet
alors juste avant et il ya une des
personnes qui dit et nous annoncer des
mauvaises nouvelles mais c'était
jean-pierre nous disait ça passait mieux
ce que l'on vient effectivement ça passe
pas aussi ça cette façon d'apaiser les
choses